Hey everybody and welcome
to the content video.
We're going over section
8.8, replacing substrings.
So when you're working with strings,
it can happen that strings sometimes
have things inside of them that
you would rather be something else.
And I'll tell you what might be
a case for that is if you have
something like a tab character or white
space within a string that you want
replaced with nothing. So the section
on this is fairly short in the
textbook, so I'm going to just go
ahead and jump over to our Cospace,
let's talk about replacing
substrings or string replacing.
Let's say we have a phrase,
this class is okay, period.
We could use the replace function to
give it a string like okay
and replace it with something
else. So for example, we could
replace okay with amazing.
I can't spell amazing.
And then if we were to print
out our phrase, we would
actually let me print out
the phrase before and after.
So
here's our phrase before
and our phrase after.
This class is okay, this class is
amazing. So that's the gist of how
it works. Like I said, sometimes we
have strings that have like spaces
or tabs or whatever else in them
that maybe we don't want and so more
commonly you'll see people looking
for a space and replacing it with no
space. So that's the more common
usage of the replace function. That's
everything for this content video
though, so thank you for watching.